es una enfermedad silenciosa y
silenciada
así es como naciones unidas- llamada la
enfermedad de chagas un mal que puede
llegar a ser mortal si no se trata a
tiempo generalmente es asintomática se
desarrolla lentamente y afecta a
poblaciones pobres la enfermedad de
chagas afecta entre 6 y 7 millones de
personas cada año en américa latina es
una enfermedad silenciosa afecta a los
más pobres los más vulnerables y mata de
espacio en tanto seis millones mujer
cerca de dos millones de mujeres en edad
fértil se ven afectadas crónicamente
afectadas escuchamos esta enfermedad que
solo es diagnosticada al 7% de quienes
la padecen es transmitida por la
picadura del insecto conocido como
chinche del tri atom ha infectado los
alimentos contaminados las transfusiones
de sangre transplantes de órganos o
incluso de madre a hijo algo contra lo
que luchan naciones unidas mucho en el
día de la enfermedad de chagas y unique
age se enorgullece en anunciar el
lanzamiento de un nuevo programa de
eliminación de la transmisión de madre a
hijo en bolivia brasil colombia y
paraguay
que se enfocará en análisis tratamiento
de atención mediante el seguimiento
sistemático a la mujer y al recién
nacidos la onu alerta sobre la necesidad
de dar a conocer esta enfermedad
tropical de la que poco se habla y de
los tratamientos que actualmente existen
para prevenir los fallecimientos que
anualmente rondan los 10 mil